alain decaux vous est donc venu à 9 ans
pour ces fêtes romantiques ça n'est pas
la première fois pour les fêtes
romantiques oui c'est la première fois
mais pour nous en ont je suis venu
plusieurs fois j'ai fait notamment et
deux émissions pour la télévision et
pour bonnes adresses du passé ça a été
un vrai un très bon souvenir avec
georges adblock et roland verna devions
tourner oui ici pendant plusieurs jours
et et vous savez quand on tourne une
émission vous avez vu personne on
découvre des tas de choses que les
visiteurs ne peut pas voir parce qu'on
s'installe dans une pièce pendant
quelques fois une demi journée on en
explore les recoins et pour moi c'est
vraiment un très grand souvenir
et cette petite place et églises c'est
toujours avec plaisir que vous les
envoyer oui c'est un vous savez quand on
arrive de paris rue de paris à l'instant
c'est une plongée dans le passé n'est
pas vraiment le toutou ce cadre tout ça
ça y est on y est on s'est dit nous
sommes il ya un siècle d'ici même avant
ça y est c'est ça nous sommes chez
georges de sang et j'en ch semble faite
autour de nous oh oui elle est là elle
est là d'ailleurs on ne peut pas
l'oublier parce que j'étais j'étais
presque stupéfait en venant de paris
tout à l'heure de voir quel point elle
est annoncée et spatiaux sur la route
très longtemps avant nous parle de
george sand on nous parle du circuit
george-sand l'on ai dit voilà où vous y
êtes vous êtes dans le pays dans le sens
et je suis en train de me demander si ce
n'est pas un privilège unique en france
parce que bon il ya des écrivains
indiscutablement qui sont beaucoup plus
lu que george sand l'espace pas faire
injure à la mémoire sur le salon là les
plus beaux coups mais prenez du mal
c'est pas les changements puisque je
parle et d'alexandre dumas ici aux fêtes
romantiques de nom d'alexandre dumas ccc
c'est l'homme qui est le plus lu en
france le romancier le plus le plus
n'est ce pas dévorer passionnément
parler france et lui on le lit et bien
c'est pas le cas à villers cotterêts
qu'ils sont pays-bas n'y a pas du tout
20 km avant vous êtes dans le pays dès
les 30 du mat serra c'est c'est pas le
cas pour balzac non plus alors là y'a un
privilège un privilège et ea c'est assez
extraordinaire et se guérit vous le
connaissez bien c'est une région riche
d'histoire oui oui pas je le connais pas
par entièrement parce que personne ne
peut se vanter de bien connaître une
province à moin en moin lé y avoir
habité ce qui n'est pas mon cas
mais enfin j'y viens lemagit bien sûr la
lisière presque du berry j'y viens près
de valence et parce que c'est là qu'on a
me albert simonin à moulins où je vais
passer des week-ends et pas tant parce
que quand on est chez elle vers six
manades on est toujours très bien nous
sommes ici dans la salle à manger de la
maison de george sand des ombres nous
entourent bien sûr tous ses amis vous
êtes à cette table à la place
d'alexandre dumas fils vous l'êtes pas
impressionner messi messi parce que j'ai
devant moi d'ailleurs la carte qui porte
son nom il s'est assis ici puisqu'il a
été l'hôte de george sand
ils étaient 1 d'ailleurs un grand ami
george sand l'ex animatrice bien sûr est
il appelé george sand maman se passait
et 20 ans entre les deux et il vous dira
qu'elle l'à beaucoup plus influencée par
ce que celui de george sand est est une
une socialisante elle l avait un social
doctrine de socialistes humanitaire qui
était tout à fait dans le goût du temps
il faut dire que ella ella notamment ce
qui concerne la femme ne s'est pas fait
beaucoup george-sand de la liberté
féminine qui était c'était pour que
l'attrait battu en brèche pour dire que
les femmes doivent beaucoup à
george-sand et faut dire que alexandre
dumas fils doit lui même beaucoup
parce qu'on s'aperçoit que dans le
terreau de dumas fils et des quantités
d'idées qui viennent directement leur
jeu 100 m
emilien a peut-être pas parce que la
dame acomplia c'est une histoire de lui
mais en fait toutes ces pièces un peu
moralisant qu'on joue plus d'ailleurs
non plus et le fils naturel et cetera
là il y a tout ay à tout un théâtre qui
vient directement de george-sand